This should go without saying that you should always love,
respect and appreciate your man.
Men absolutely love being spoiled just as much as women do.
So how do you do that? Has he had a hard day?
Give him a massage. Give him back scratches.
Men absolutely die for this.
He wanna go golfing? Let him go golfing.
Not only that, pack him a snack and a drink.
Has he been working out? Or maybe he's just looking extra handsome.
Tell him that men love compliments just as much as women do.
Another thing you can do is initiate intimacy.
Men love this. You do this and it's like getting a dozen roses.
Not kidding. This is so,
so important to make sure you appreciate and thank your man.
This, to men,
is like getting a whole room filled with roses.
I'm telling you right now that if you respect and appreciate your man
and show him that is the most rewarding for them.
And do not forget that all men deserve flowers too.